انا تايه لقيت عندي انا حاليا تايه في
منطقه عبسان الكبرى في عندي جنود كثير
فوانا قاعد ماشي في شوارع خلا لقيت الحج
ايش يا حج اهلا وسهلا حاج انت كيف قاعد ه
ما صار له يومين ت هان وش والله انا
بالنسبه لي انا مبعد من سجن اسرائيل وجيت
على البلد هي لي ع سنين ومريض ومعي السكر
وعندي كسور بجسمي بقدرش اروح على مدرسه او
على او على مقر من اللي في التجمعات لانه
بدي مين يخدمني وبدي مرحاض فرنجي طب يا
حاج قصدي انه فيش ولا حد حرفيا المربعات
هي كلياتها فيش الا انت انا شايف ما شو
بدي اسوي انا متعود على الحروب وحضرت حروب
كثيره وبتمنى اكون ان بالجبهه انا بتمنى
هلا اكون بالجبهه بال 2014 شاركت مع شاركت
كنت مع الدفاع المدني بس انا وضعي صعب
شويه وبتمنى اكون بتمنى
الشهاده